hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and I spent
another lazy week at my house this week
because I watched a Netflix movie lack
near Bandersnatch I know it's a
fictional character I know it's the
thing that they didn't just make up but
Bandersnatch sounds like one of the
alternate words that people use when
they're making fun of Benedict
Cumberbatch is that his name see
Benedict Bandersnatch it just sounds
like one that's to me if you saw last
week's video you know that I'm a
self-proclaimed Netflix fangirl I want
to act on Netflix with all my heart I
think what they're doing is so
innovative it's so so good and mostly
just incredibly well done
so seeing this interactive
choose-your-own-adventure movie was
really cool I grew up with the choose
your own adventure books as I think a
lot of people did also though this style
is on YouTube there are YouTube videos
that are choose-your-own-adventure I
know this because Rob Scallon has done a
couple of them and they are an insane
amount of work and in the movie you see
our main characters - fan mapping it out
himself and struggling with it this is
so new though in a movie kind of aspect
I know it's been done on a very smaller
scale before like final destination one
of them you could choose how you died at
the ends I had such a good time watching
this it's kind of hard to talk about I'm
gonna try not to do any spoilers um it's
kind of impossible not take this so
there will be light spoilers in this I
had a great time going through it it
didn't read to me like a movie at all
kind of like until dawn that that video
game where you just kind of choose a or
b and that determines what happens and
who lives and who dies kind of similar
to that I felt very videogame II and
they did such a good job with the story
of this because he's making a video game
and there are alternate realities in his
world and it is all very meta for him
and so it worked then it felt that way
and I
for them to have a story that was like I
don't know about this architect who
loves math it just it wouldn't work it
worked so well that he was making a
video game and all these other things
alternate reality isn't like you know
he's on acid you know he a lot of
cleaners combined to make you believe it
you don't have to suspend your
believability to too much because they
kind of just wrote it into the story
which I really like I think there's
definite problems with it but again they
explained a lot of those away and that
worked for me at least and for how good
it is for like this first giant attempt
at this style on a larger platform I
think it's so so so well done this story
starts off in 1984 which I've heard is
Aiden odd of course to the book 1984 and
then also it is a nod to the videogame
Bandersnatch which was developed in 1984
and never released this is the only
black mirror episode that takes place in
the past though all of the rest take
place in the very near future it's cool
to have things switched up for you like
that but also they did a great job with
it being sent in 1984 but you're still
talking to him from the future it's it's
there's a portion that's very weirdly
meta I think it's my least favorite part
of the whole experience and you talk to
him through his computer and you can
either choose it's an easter egg from
another black amir episode or you can
choose netflix
what's talking to him what is deciding
all these choices for him and if you
choose the netflix option you're like
i'm a streaming service from the future
and he's like I don't get that it's like
well it's like TV but it's online and
he's like huh and it's a little weird I
do think though with the different
endings that the rewatch ability is so
high and I sat there after finishing my
timeline
and watch all of the endings at the end
you kind of finish your timeline up and
then they give you options for if you
would have chosen different paths along
the way I also enjoy that because it can
get a little anxious a little anxiety
ridden to determine this man's fate by
choosing Sugar Puffs over frosted flakes
and so to see the different timelines
work out after you've completed your own
is really nice some of the questions are
Sugar Puffs are frosted flakes and that
is it seems more like a fun thing like
uh this is kind of how this works and
this really isn't going to impact your
story too much and then there's there's
questions like accept this job or don't
accept this job and those feel very
important and the way I play video game
and choose your adventure games and any
kind of story driven games where you get
to make a choice
I am always I play the good guy I always
go in with the intention of playing the
bad guy like aw yeah hell yeah I'm gonna
be the the cool bad guy this time
whenever I can never bring myself to do
it ever ever so I played it very safe
until about 3/4 of the way in I played
it extremely safe and then I was like I
just really want to know though so I
started playing a dirty and it blurred
the lines of my gaming technique I'll
say that Sugar Puffs or frosted flakes
obviously Sugar Puffs obviously
obviously Stefon knows that he's being
controlled by something he just doesn't
know what it is and it's kind of hinted
at that it's like Bandersnatch is doing
this to him this is the game is doing
this to him and like this new technology
and this weird content is doing this to
him for the first time on that I played
out his game does poorly and you start
completely over that's just a new
alternate reality for him and it's cool
but it does slightly take you out of it
I think there's also moments where if
you've made too many wrong choices
they'll be like no no you can't do that
so we're gonna bring you back make
another choice again and you have to
make a different choice which I liked
because it was kind of steering you in
the right way and then you get further
into the movie and it's talking a lot
about freewill and how nothing is free
well like you don't actually make the
choices that you're making and like it's
very like in your face telling you that
you're not really making that many
choices I am really bad at paying
attention to fill what am I doing here
on the internet reviewing Phillips Kunis
I sometimes though if I'm watching
something that just doesn't capture my
immediate attention
ever hard time staying super focused I
miss small subtleties and details if the
movie has small subtleties and details
usually the bad ones that I zone out on
don't have that many subtleties
but this was a surefire way to keep me
engaged and it's just it's it's gonna
keep you super super engaged there's no
way you kids you can't put down your
controller you can it vibrates very
loudly if you do so you'll you'll no
one's choose it but you're always up on
your toes you're always focused you're
always very in it you're always trying
to figure out what your next move is and
I really enjoy that it's super
interactive it's so interesting I think
that I prefer the show black mirror more
than this like interactive experience
but there's something to this it's very
cool it's very new I applaud them for
just going straight on in diving in and
just doing a really good job with it I
think this is something that we're gonna
see a lot more of in the future and for
them to have just basically just done it
first done it really well first it's so
cool I love you Netflix the things that
I think could improve is just the
moments that I take you out of the story
I think this story is really good they
did they chose the best story they could
for something like this and there's
moments where you are taken out because
either the choice screen comes up and
you have to choose and then they zoom in
on the face
like what are you gonna do and then it
cuts to whatever choice you made or you
make too many bad choices and it brings
you to the big this end scene where like
he's like sitting there like kind of bum
you have to choose again a new thing and
there's moments that kind of take you
out of it and in that that's what makes
it feel less of a movie more of like a
video game I love gaming so I'm not yeah
I'm not complaining it's supposed to be
like a movie though I'm pretty sure and
then I think it was maybe a slight
misstep with the Vanetta
Netflix call-out was just a little weird
I don't know let me know if you liked
that because I laughed when I saw it I
enjoyed it I guess it just felt a little
weird and then a lot of the endings that
I played back and went back to I had
that in it and so I rewatched that
that's another thing there's a lot of
rewatching content which didn't bother
me they get shorter shorter and shorter
or how many times you've seen them they
go to quicker cuts but you do see a lot
of the same stuff and so I saw that
Netflix sequence like six times and it
it was a little silly after the second I
think the cool things though is it so
new it's so so fresh so well done I
think we're gonna be seeing a lot more
of this style I think as an actor
working on this must have been so cool
can you imagine getting that script and
seeing all these different cool things
you get to play out it's just I love the
thought of being an actor in something
like this anyways put your thoughts down
below I think this is a difficult movie
to like review or react to but I really
want to talk to someone about it I
haven't spoken to anyone about it I'm
just talking to a camera lens hello
little bear and so I don't know I think
this is a great conversation is this
gonna turn into a drinking game kind of
deal or you come over to someone's house
and you all have it I don't know you
know what you know me like a social
thing is the rewatch ability that great
or is it not cuz no I watched it once I
saw the endings I feel like I've gotten
out of it what I'm gonna get out of it
so what do you think let me know thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
all next week
with a movie from the theater
[Music]